a grand jury in the District of Columbia
today returned an indictment presented
by the special counsels office the
indictment charges thirteen Russian
nationals and three Russian companies
for committing federal crimes while
seeking to interfere in the United
States political system including the
2016 presidential election with the
stated goal of spreading distrust
towards the candidates and the political
system in general now there is no
allegation in this indictment that any
American was a knowing participant in
this illegal activity there is no
allegation in the indictment that the
charged conduct altered the outcome of
the 2016 election a rocky news day here
on Washington on a Friday let's bring in
our panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Marie harf is a former spokeswoman at
the State Department and match slap
contributor with the hill gentlemen lady
good evening hello your reaction to what
you heard there these indictments today
it's rather shocking everything about it
is it's shocking it's shocking to see
the Deputy Attorney General to me making
that announcement it didn't come
specifically from the special counsels
team it's shocking that what they're
saying is that these you know it's
really interesting they said these
Russians were spreading discord
you know I'm lose they're serious
charges but that was a strange word it
seemed to use right it's weird that they
said they've been doing it for a number
of years maybe before this election
cycle you know it didn't seem like that
genius a plan to to get on Twitter and
talk to you know to say bad things about
Hillary Clinton and other candidates and
I think for a lot of Republicans they're
kind of singing that song after all of
this is that all there is and if that
really is all there is the American
people are going to want to move on
Murray you have a diplomatic background
how surprised were you by what you heard
today well I don't think that's all
there is I think this is the latest
round and it's clear that Bob Muller is
pulling a lot of different threads here
and it really outlines for the American
people the extent in this one piece of
Russia is disinformation campaign the
American people should be concerned the
they may have seen social media posts
that were disinformation from Russians
that they may have attended rallies
organized by these Russian BOTS and I
think for a lot of people underscores
the fact that this is not a hoax
the Russian meddling is real and Israel
this week you had the intelligence
chiefs up on the hill saying they're
still trying to do this in 2018 and 2020
it is a serious ongoing threat that
needs to be treated that way by the
administration there's another
revelation today that the Russians were
so sneaky they're doing events for and
against candidate Trump take a listen to
this after the election the defendants
allegedly staged rallies to support the
president-elect while simultaneously
staging rallies to protest his election
for example the defendants organized one
rally to support the president-elect and
another rally to impose to oppose him
both in New York on the same day both in
New York on the same day Byron your
reaction to what you've heard well I
think actually what Rosen Stein just
said there supports this idea that they
were there was really twofold to disrupt
our system to sow discord and to mess
with Hillary Clinton whom they thought
was going to be the president and so
there were there were lesser targets
they Bernie Sanders they wanted to
support him and Jill Stein they wanted
to support her but again that was all
kind of Hillary focused just as they're
supportive Trump was then the
unthinkable happens Trump wins and they
just begin to disrupt in a different way
putting on two rallies in New York one a
pro Trump rally and the other is Trump
is not my president rally so I think it
just supports the idea that they were
just messing with things the whole time
Murray what do you think their reaction
was in Moscow to this well it's probably
not surprising and none of these people
that were charged will ever see a US
Court Russia will not extradite them I
don't think but it's put them on notice
and for a lot of people part of what's
been concerning to some about the fact
that President Trump keeps calling this
idea that Russia meddled a hoax right
that he doesn't seem to accept the
intelligence community's assessment it's
because what they need to be doing right
now is planning to prevent it next time
and that testimony this week from the
intelligence chiefs should be very
stunning to Americans they are still
doing this stuff and yes it's just
Facebook and Twitter a lot of Americans
get their news from Facebook and this is
rather absurd this is like rocky
Bullwinkle kind of stuff when I think of
Russian Russian collusion in our
elections I am offended
I think it's repulsive is this what it
was it was searching guys having some
rallies acting as BOTS on social media
somebody might have read a Facebook post
that was incorrect that's what this was
all about it's repugnant it shouldn't
happen Obama should have stopped it but
by the same token this is not worth a
year of the country's time over
everything else that we have to deal
with in this country and these charges
of Russian collusion it's clearly been
ridiculous and not true it's not a
surprise either I mean the intelligence
committees on Capitol Hill have known
almost everything that's in this
indictment a lot of it's been actually
reported in the press and remember there
was just a lot a huge excitement over
the Facebook ads a while back with the
intelligence committees which really
added up to very very little most of
them ran after the election yes I want
to get to the other bombshell news today
regarding the FBI that they got a tip
about this young man and it fell through
the cracks as a dad I find that
particularly devastating your reaction
to that Matt yeah no I mean look law
enforcement they have a tough job and
they're not gonna catch every you know
bad person that wants to do harm in
society that being said I think this is
just not acceptable to the American
people to know that these were not just
somebody saying some something bad about
a guy this is like calling the FBI and
telling them chapter and verse and why
this person was a threat Marie you've
worked at higher levels of our
government does somebody lose their job
for this someone probably should and I
don't think it's just one person though
it this has to be a systematic look at
how we how we go about this because
we've always heard if you see something
say something right we can there are bad
people out there but you go to the FBI
because you trust that they will act on
it we need to take a look top to bottom
at how this was handled someone may
probably should lose their job over this
but we can't just blame it on one person
we need to take a look at this we need
to look at gun laws we need to look at
mental health Oh
of it in the wake of something like this
because we have to prevent this from
happening again and for the FBI itself a
lot of Republicans have been very
critical of the FBI's handling of highly
politicized investigations the Clinton
email investigation the Trump Russia
investigation but at the same time
praising the work that the FBI does in
fighting crime around the country and to
have this horrendous mistake happened
it's just really bad a lot of folks
behind us on Capitol Hill warning about
undermining the FBI but this is a few at
the FBI undermining the agency itself